-♪ High kickin', high kickin' ♪
♪ That's kickin' way up high ♪
♪ High kickin', high kickin' ♪
♪ Our shoes gon' touch the sky ♪
-♪ Since we were babies,
we've been kickin' up a storm ♪
♪ We started kickin'
before we were born ♪
-♪ Our feet start low,
and then our feet go up ♪
♪ Our toes in the air ♪
♪ We just can't get enough ♪
-♪ I can kick a wall,
kick a tree that's tall ♪
♪ I can kick a shelf
that's full of dolls ♪
-♪ I can kick a brew,
kick a Subaru ♪
♪ I can kick the Moon ♪
-♪ But I'd never kick you ♪
♪ High kickin', high kickin' ♪
♪ That's kickin' way up high ♪
♪ Our shoes gon' touch the sky ♪
-♪ As you can see,
we clearly love to kick ♪
♪ But it's had a negative impact
on relationships ♪
-♪ Girls see us kicking ♪
♪ Then ask us to leave ♪
♪ Got fired from Foot Locker
for kickin' my boss Steve ♪
-♪ Kicked out of my school,
kicked out of the pool ♪
♪ Kicked out of a church
'cause I broke the rules ♪
-♪ Kicked out of the mall,
out of Montreal ♪
♪ Off the soccer field
'cause we kicked their balls ♪
-♪ High kickin', high kickin' ♪
♪ That's kickin' way up high ♪
♪ High kickin', high kickin' ♪
♪ Our shoes gon' touch the sky ♪
♪ So maybe
we should kick kickin' ♪
♪ By which I mean
we should stop ♪
♪ This resolution is stickin' ♪
♪ 'Cause we can totally stop ♪
[ Music stops ]
Snack break.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Yawns ]
That's a lot of Sammies.
-Piled up so high
yet right at foot level.
[ Laughter ]
-We're so hungry,
and food is for eating,
not for kicking.
[ Laughter ]
-So, we'll eat the sandwiches
and not kick them.
-Agreed.
[ Laughter ]
[ Grunting ]
Want to kick.
-Kick it, kick it...
Yeah, yeah, y-e-e-e-ah!
♪ High kickin', high kickin' ♪
♪ That's kickin' way up high ♪
♪ Our shoes gon' touch the sky ♪
♪ Wow, wow, wow ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]